それでは、こんしゅうのざっくばらんなお話からはじめていきますね。
まず最初は、「エーアイネイティブな時代のユーザー体験」についてです。
ここ三年ほど、私はGraphAI、MulmoCast、MulmoChat、MulmoClaude、MulmoTerminalといった、さまざまなオープンソースのプロジェクトを立ち上げてきました。
これは、二千年にUIEvolutionを立ち上げて、マネジメントバイアウトを経て二度売却した後に、私自身が「会社作りよりも、モノづくりの方が本当にやりたいことなんだ」と気付いた、その結果生まれたものなんです。
「そろそろビジネスにしなきゃな」とは考えているのですが、どうしても頭に浮かんでくるのは「作りたいもの」ばかりでして、やっぱり私は「自分が作ったものを製品化してビジネスにしてくれるパートナー」が必要なんだなとつくづく感じています。
そんななかで、一つ「これは絶対に作ってみたい」というものがはっきり見えてきました。
このアイディアはMulmoChatを作った頃からずっとあたためていたものなんですが、その後MulmoClaudeやMulmoTerminalを作っていく中で、より明確になってきたんです。
それは、自然言語を理解するエルエルエムが当たりまえになった時代にふさわしい、「エーアイネイティブなユーザー体験」です。
コンピュータのユーザー体験は、大きく分けると、キャラクターユーザーインターフェイス（CUI）から、グラフィカルユーザーインターフェイス（GUI）へと変化し、さらにChatGPTの誕生によって、それがナチュラルランゲージユーザーインターフェイス（NLUI）へと進化しつつあるんですね。
ただ、このNLUIはまだ本当に黎明期で、状況としては混沌としています。
ChatGPTも基本的にはCUIですし、GUIとの融合もまだ中途半端です。
アマゾンのAlexaやアップルのSiriは、ボイスチャットのパイオニアだったんですが、それ以降は進化が止まってしまっています。
メタはスマートグラスを通じて、エーアイアシスタントのじっそうを始めていますが、これもまだ始まったばかりという段階です。
今の状況を例えるなら、GUIで言うMacintoshやWindows95がまだ生まれていない段階なんですよね。
MulmoChatはこの問題への答えを探るために作ったパソコン上のプロトタイプで、完成品には程遠いのですが、その過程で生まれたMCPを拡張する「GUI Chat Protocol」は、GUIとNLUIを橋渡しする非常に重要なプロトコルで、MulmoClaudeやMulmoTerminalでも大いに活用しています。
さらにMulmoClaude上でデータベースアプリを作るコレクションという仕組みがあるのですが、これはエンジニアじゃない人でも「必要に応じて自分専用のアプリを作れる」という、とても重要な仕組みなんです。
これこそが「エーアイネイティブなOSのプログラミング環境」としてぴったりだと思っています。
そこで次のステップとして「エーアイネイティブなユーザー体験」をハードからソフトまでエンド・ツー・エンドで作ってみようと考えているところです。
ハードウェアとしては、多分Raspberry Piくらいで十分で、その上でNodeサーバーとブラウザを動かして、GUI Chat Protocolを最大限活かしたユーザー体験を提供するエーアイアシスタントを作りたいと考えています。
最初はキッチンに置く目覚まし時計ぐらいの大きさのデバイス、つまりディスプレイ、カメラ、マイク、スピーカー付き、こんなものでじっそうし、あとから四足歩行のロボットに進化させても面白いかなと。
もちろん、ディスプレイの技術が大きく進歩したら、スマートグラス上にじっそうするのもありですが、そこは焦らずじっくりと攻めていくのが賢明だと思っています。
ビジネスの立ち上げ方はいろいろと考えられますが、まずは実際に体験できるデバイスを作るのが一番だと考えています。
Windows95の時も、私が作ったプロトタイプからスタートしました。
GUIパソコンの次に来る、エーアイネイティブなコンピュータのユーザー体験はどうあるべきなのか、今度はハードウェア込みのプロトタイプを使って世の中に見せてみたいと強く思っています。
続いて、「メタトレンド投資」についてです。
9月初めの日本出張中は、一日二本くらいのペースでYouTubeのインタビューを受けていました。
主な目的は、書籍「2034みらいよそく」のプロモーションなのですが、一つ前の書籍「メタトレンド投資」にからめた株の話の方が視聴数が伸びるので、どうしてもそっちの話題になることが多いです。
そうなると、どうしても「次のエヌビディアはどこですか？
」という質問を受けるのですが、もしそれが分かれば苦労しませんよね。
私の投資手法をひとことで言えば、
時代の大きな流れ、つまりメタトレンドを読み取って、その変化をリードしそうな企業に長期投資をする、というやり方なんです。
一つ目の「流れを読む」という部分は、しっかりとアンテナを張っていれば、かなり正確に予測できるんですけど、二つ目の「その変化をけん引する会社」を確実に当てる方法なんてありません。
自分で商品を買ったり、シーイーオーのカリスマ性をみたりして評価はしますが、確実に分かる部分と、そうでない部分はきちんと分けて考える必要があります。
そこで、いくつかの技術革新について、「メタトレンド投資」という視点から、何が今見えていて、何が見えていないのか、私なりに整理してお話ししたいと思います。
AIが私たちの生活や社会に、インターネットやスマホ以上のインパクトをもたらすことは間違いありません。
あと十年もすれば、仕事や生活のあらゆる場面でAIが使われるようになって、それ以前にAIなしで社会がどうやって動いていたか想像できないくらいになるでしょう。
24時間、私たちが見たり聞いたりしているものを一緒に把握して、アドバイスや作業をしてくれる「AIアシスタント」がごく当たり前になり、科学の進歩の大半もAIが加速していく時代が来るでしょうね。
ただ、どんな会社が今後伸びるのかを予想するのはそんなに簡単ではありません。
エヌビディアや、ハイパースケーラー、たとえばマイクロソフトやアマゾン、グーグルなどの巨大なAIデータセンターを運営している企業のビジネスが伸びるのは当然ですが、すでに株価にそれが織り込まれているとも言えます。
ここから十倍、百倍を狙うとなると、そういう株ではないとも言えるんですね。
今年から来年にかけては、フロンティア・ラボと呼ばれる、最先端のAIモデルを提供する会社、たとえばAnthropicやOpenAIが上場するんじゃないか、という観測もあるのですが、中長期的に彼らが堅実に利益を上げる企業として成長し続ける保証はありません。
グーグル、xAI、メタを交えた争いは熾烈ですし、オープンウェイトなモデルも激しく追い上げてきているので、コモディティ化して利益が出なくなるビジネスになる可能性も十分に考えられます。
ここからは「半導体」についてです。
AIの時代には、「知能」とか「思考」といったものがインフラやサービスとして提供されるようになりますが、そこに欠かせないのが半導体なんです。
そんな中で、「エヌビディアの一強状態がいつ崩れるか」を予測するのはまったく簡単じゃないですが、エヌビディアの大口顧客、つまりグーグルやアマゾン、OpenAIなどが自分たちでチップを作り始めているのは注目すべき動きなんです。
その背景には、AIが優秀になっているおかげで、半導体の設計や半導体の上で動かすソフトウェアの最適化コストが大きく下がっているというトレンドがあります。
これってとても大事なことなんです。
かつてはエヌビディアみたいなチップ専業メーカーにしかできなかったことが、大きな顧客自らの手の届くところまで降りてきていて、それがエヌビディアの強みを中長期的に脅かす原因になり得ます。
さらに、半導体に関しては「台湾リスク」という側面も無視できません。
これが軍事力なのか政治力を使うのかは分からないですが、中国が台湾を併合することは時間の問題だと指摘する専門家もいますし、台湾以外の西側の国で最先端の半導体を一日でも早く生産できる体制を整えるのは、安全保障の観点から本当に急ぐべき課題です。
この観点から見れば、TSMCの海外工場、たとえばアリゾナや熊本の工場といったもの、それからサムスンやラピダス、テスラとSpaceXが計画している自社半導体工場「テラファブ」など、こういったプロジェクトがすごく大きな役割を果たす可能性が十分にあるんです。
長期投資の対象として、こうした動きに注目するのは悪くない選択だと思います。
続いて「フィジカルエーアイ」についてお話します。
既にAIは、多くのホワイトカラーの職業を置き換えられるレベルまで進歩していますが、その次にやってくる波は、ロボットやドローン、自動運転車などを使った肉体労働の代替です。
これまでなかなかビジネスとして立ち上がらなかった人型、つまりヒューマノイドロボットがAIの進化によって、いよいよ社会のいろんな場面で活用される時代になりつつあります。
この分野では中国のロボットベンチャーがすごく目立っていますが、テスラ、Figure AI、Boston Dynamicsの三社が、それぞれ工場で使うことを重視して開発しているのも本当に注目すべき点です。
いまはヒューマノイドの進化がめざましいので、どうしてもそっちばかりにみんなの注目が集まりがちなんですが、実は既存の工場向け産業ロボットにもAI技術を適用する余地はすごく大きいんです。
その結果、新しい価値が生まれてしじょう全体が拡大していく可能性は高いですし、そうしたトレンドにうまく乗れる企業は、大きく成長していくでしょう。
ハードについてみてみると、モーターや減速機、バッテリー、それから量産体制に至るまで、中国の勢いは圧倒的なんです。
ただ、エレクトリックビークルや太陽光パネルの分野で中国のサプライチェーンに頼りすぎたことをアメリカが反省したため、ロボットやドローンの領域では中国製を排除する方向に動いています。
そして、その穴を埋めることができるのは、精密部品や産業ロボットでしっかりとした実績がある日本と韓国なんですね。
ここに「特需」が生まれる可能性は非常に高いですし、そのチャンスをしっかり捉えることができれば、大きな成長が期待できる企業も出てくると思います。
自動運転の話から始めます。
自動運転というのは、乗用車だけじゃなくて、トラックやトラクター、コンバインといった農業機械、それから建設機械なんかにも広く応用できるので、そこに大きな可能性があるんです。
分かりやすい例で言えばドローンですね。
ドローンって、一台にひとりのパイロットが必要なうちは、結局ドローンのしじょう規模はパイロットの数と人件費で頭打ちになってしまうんです。
でも、自動運転になった瞬間、そういう制限はなくなります。
それによって、今まで応用できなかった範囲にまで広げることができて、全体としてしじょうそのものがすうじゅうばいからすうひゃくばいにも成長する可能性が十分にあると思っています。
続いて、医療や素材の分野におけるエーアイについてです。
エーアイによって科学の進歩がどんどん加速すると期待されていますが、目の前で社会に大きな価値を提供できそうな分野としては、新しい薬とか素材の開発がその一つです。
グーグル DeepMindがかいはつしたAlphaFoldから始まった、タンパク質の構造を予測したり設計するエーアイは、これまで莫大な時間とコストがかかっていた創薬のプロセスを劇的に短縮できるかもしれません。
たとえば、特定のがん細胞を攻撃する薬をオンデマンドで作ったり、特定の部位に指令を送るホルモンなんかを人為的に作るのが簡単になるかもしれないと期待されています。
もちろん、健康にかかわる分野なので規制も厳しくて、IT系の企業がこの分野で単独でビジネスを展開するのは簡単じゃありません。
ですので、既存の医薬品メーカーなんかと協力する形でしじょうが成長していくのが現実的だと思います。
なので、医薬品メーカーとIT企業が今後どんな関係を築いていくのか、これを注目して見ていくのがいいと思います。
エーアイの強みは、24時間休まずに大量の実験を繰り返すことができる点なんですが、やっぱり実際の実験装置を使うとなると、そこがボトルネックになりがちです。
そういう意味で、シミュレーションの技術がこの先ますます重要になります。
しかも、ミクロの世界で物質の振る舞いをシミュレーションする時には量子の効果を無視できないので、そこにこそ量子コンピュータの活躍が期待できるんじゃないかと思っています。
ただし、実用的な量子コンピュータがいつ登場するのか、どの企業がそれを実現するのかは、今の時点では全く見えていない部分です。
ここまで並べてみると、今「見えている」のはメタトレンドそのもので、「見えていない」のはそのトレンドの中でどの企業が勝つのか、ということなんです。
なので私は、「次のエヌビディア」を一社に絞ろうとはせずに、確信のあるトレンドごとに、その恩恵を受けそうな企業を複数選んで、ながい目で持つというやり方をとっています。
高騰する銘柄をピンポイントで当てるのはむずかしいですが、トレンドに乗ること自体は十分可能だよ、ということになります。
続いて、3Dプリンタの話題です。
Astraに3Dモデルを作らせていたら、ひさしぶりに3Dプリンタを動かしたくなりました。
ちょうど三年ほど前にキッチン用に作ったパーツが壊れてしまったので、いい機会かなと考えたんです。
それで、二年ほど放置していた三Dプリンタ「Ender 3 Pro」でひさしぶりにプリントしようとしたんですが、なかなか素直に動いてくれなくて、すごく苦労しました。
さいしょはノズルが怪しいと思って交換してみたもののうまくいかず、フィラメントも新品に替えたけどやっぱりプリントできません。
マットにうまく吸着してくれないんです。
今度はマットも新品に替えましたが、それでも動かず、四苦八苦していたら妻が「新しい三Dプリンタを買い直した方がいいんじゃない？
あなたの時給で考えてみたら？
」と指摘します。
「Ender 3 Pro」はだいたい三百ドルくらいだったので、その修理に何日もかけるのは確かに合理的じゃありませんね。
そこでネットで調べた結果、「Bambu Lab A1」というモデルがまさに私のニーズにぴったりだと分かったんです。
何よりメンテナンスが楽だという評判ですし、二十五センチ×二十五センチ×二十五センチの大きさまでプリントできる点もとても気に入りました。
さっそくアマゾンで購入して使ってみたところ、「Ender 3 Pro」と比べると格段の進化を感じました。
セットアップもだいぶ簡単になってるし、ノズルのクリーンアップやレベリングもすべて全自動になっています。
WiFi経由でパソコンから直接プリントの指示ができるのもすごく便利です（「Ender 3 Pro」はメモリーカード経由なので）。
ソフトウェアもとてもよくできていて、どんな会社が作ってるのか調べたら、元DJI（ドローンしじょうで世界ナンバーワンの会社）のエンジニアたちが二千二十年に立ち上げた中国・シンセンのベンチャー企業なんです。
「三DプリンタのDJI」を目指している会社、ということでした。
ここ数年で「ホビイスト向けの工作機械」から、「気軽に使える家電」へと大きく進化したな、と感じました。
もし、何年か前に「もう少し三Dプリンタが使いやすくなれば買ってもいい」と思っていたなら、いまこそそのタイミングなのかもしれません。
さて、ここからは、ロボティックス・エンジニアになる方法についての話題です。
このメルマガでは、理系の学生さんから卒業後のキャリアについて相談されることがよくあります。
もし今、私が学生だったら、ソフトウェアはもちろん、ハードの勉強もしっかりやって、学生のうちにドローンや小型のロボット、自動運転車くらいは自作する経験を積んでいるだろうと思うんです。
というのも、単なるソフトウェア制作のコストはエーアイの進化で劇的に下がってきていて、ソフトウェア単体で勝負するのはどんどんむずかしくなる時代が来ています。
「エーアイ革命」の第二フェーズは、ロボット・ドローン・自動運転車といったものを絡めたフィジカルエーアイ、つまり実世界で動くエーアイになるのが明らかです。
これからは、ソフトウェアとハードウェアの両方を使いこなせるエンジニアが活躍する時代が来ると思います。
そんなことを考えていた時、「
[EN]How to become a Robotics Engineer in 6 months (6ヶ月でロボティックス・エンジニアになる方法)[/EN]
」という記事が目にとまったので、紹介したいと思います。
記事の著者は、FigureやSkild エーアイ（どちらもヒューマノイドや汎用ロボットをかいはつするアメリカのスタートアップ企業）の実際の求人票をじっくり読み込んだうえで、四つの共通点を挙げていました。
一つ目はC++とPythonの両方が書けること。
二つ目はシミュレーションだけでなく、実機での経験があること。
そして、八つの専門分野――知覚、制御、動作計画、ロボット学習、組み込み、シミュレーション、システム統合、運用――のうち少なくとも一つの分野で深い知識があり、残りは会話ができるくらい知っていること。
そして最後に、デバッグが独立したスキルとして名指しされていることです。
逆にいうと、どの求人票にも「特定の学位」は記載されていなかった、というのが著者の指摘でした。
この記事のロードマップの内容は、毎月「作るものごと」に区切られています。
まず一ヶ月目は電子回路の基礎やテスターの使い方、はんだ付け、それからPythonとGitの学習です。
二ヶ月目はマイコン（Arduinoや、WiFi付きで安いESP32）を使ってモーターとセンサーを動かし、ライントレースロボットと倒立振子――いわゆるセグウェイのように倒れずに立ち続ける二輪ロボット――を作る。
三ヶ月目はCAD（3D設計ソフト）と3Dプリンタで自分だけの部品を作り、SO-101というオープンソースのロボットアームを組み立てます。
四ヶ月目はROS 2（ロボット開発者が共通で使うオペレーティングシステム）やシミュレーターで、部屋の地図を自動で作成して自律走行させる課題。
五ヶ月目は、それまでライブラリ任せにしていた中身――PID制御（誤差をもとに出力を調整する制御の基本）、運動学、カメラのキャリブレーション――を自分でじっそうします。
そして六ヶ月目はロボット学習と、就職活動という流れです。
かかるお金についても具体的に書かれています。
さいしょの一歩は0円、つまりブラウザ上で回路シミュレーターと無料の教科書を使うという形です。
入門キットとテスターで四十五から六十ドル、はんだごても揃えて合計百十から百六十ドル。
ライントレースロボットで三十八から百五ドル、倒立振子が六十二から百三十四ドル。
ロボットアームSO-101はパーツを全部揃えると、操作側と作業側の二本一組で二百二十九ドル八十八セント、つまり約三万五千円くらい。
一本だけなら百二十一ドル九十四セントです。
そして四ヶ月目のROS 2やシミュレーション、六ヶ月目の強化学習の入口までは、実際の機体やエヌビディアのジーピーユーも必要なく、手元のノートパソコンだけで全てできると何度も強調されています。
「ロボティクスは高価な機材が必要だ」という思い込みこそが、人が取り組まない最大の理由なんだ、ということなんです。
この記事の中で、私が一番読む価値があると感じたのは、さいごの六ヶ月目の内容です。
この二年間でロボティクス分野がどう変わったかというと、ロボットの動きを「プログラムする」のではなくて、「見せて覚えさせる」やり方が現実になったということです。
LeRobot（Hugging Faceが公開しているロボット学習ライブラリ）が採用しているのはteleoperation（遠隔操作。
ここでは、人間が操作側のアームを自分の手で動かすと、作業側のアームがその通りの動きをする仕組み）で、人間が実際にお手本を見せる。
それを映像と関節の動きデータで記録し、そのデータから方策――つまりどう動くかを決めるモデル――を学習させたあとは、ロボットが自分で動く、という流れです。
この記事の著者が挙げていた実習課題が本当に秀逸で、「積み木を箱に入れる動作をお手本として五十回記録し、学習させてみよう。
たぶん半分ぐらいしか成功しないから、今度は失敗したケースを狙って五十回追加で記録し、再学習してみよう。
そして成功率が何パーセントから何パーセントまで上がったのかを書き残してみよう」というものです。
この「計測した」という事実自体が、自分のポートフォリオになる、という考え方です。
Crunchbaseの情報によると、フィジカルエーアイのスタートアップ企業は、二千二十六年上半期だけで五百二十一件、四百七十四億ドル――日本円にして約七兆円――を調達しています。
これは二千二十二年から二千二十四年の三年分合計、四百十九億ドルを上回る金額です。
Waymoの百六十億ドル、日本円で約二兆四千億円の一件が、全体の三分の一以上を占めていて、資金が上位に非常に極端に集中しているんです。
いっぽうで、雇用のほうはまったく追いついていません。
お金が人材よりも速く流れ込んできていて、不足しているのは特定の専門ぶんやに偏っている。
そして、その入口が、学位のない人にもめずらしく開かれている――著者はそんな結論を出しています。
実際、求人件数でいちばん多かった職種はエンジニアではなく、「オートメーション・ロボティクス技術者」で全体の二十点三パーセント。
そして、そのうち六十八パーセントは短大卒レベルの資格で十分とされています。
報酬の方も、公式の統計、O*NETやBLSによる中央値が十二万二千九百三十ドル、つまり約千八百万円。
未経験のレベルでも八万ドルから十万ドル、Figure社が出しているHelixエーアイエンジニアの求人の場合は、基本給だけで二十万から四十万ドル、日本円にして三千万円から六千万円が提示されています。
この記事が示しているロードマップの中身――例えばROS2、Gazebo、MuJoCo、LeRobot、MITやバークレーの講義といったものは、ほとんどすべてが無料で利用できますし、国籍も居住地も問われません。
この分野では、学歴以上に経験のほうが重要になっているんです。
ハンダゴテを一度も握ったことがない理系大学卒よりも、ハンダゴテや三ディープリンタを自在に使いこなせる高専卒の方が市場価値が高い、そういう時代がすぐそこにやってきそうです。
続いて、ここからは非決定論的になってしまったプログラミングの話題です。
ニューラルネットは今までのソフトウェアとちがって非決定的、つまりnon-deterministicなんだということについては、以前にもここでお話してきました。
従来型のソフトウェアは、バグさえなければ、特定のインプットに対しては毎回同じアウトプットが返ってきますよね。
ところが、確率的に動くニューラルネットを使ったエルエルエムの場合、同じプロンプトでも回答が毎回少しずつ変わるんです。
これがニューラルネットの面白いところであり、同時に怖いところでもあるんですが、その点をさらに深掘りしている記事を見つけたので紹介します。
[EN]An age of experimentation (BlueHat Asia 2026)[/EN]
セキュリティ研究者として有名なトーマス・ドゥリエンさん、Halvar Flakeの名前でも知られていて、いまはオープンエーアイのセキュリティ研究チームに所属していますが、彼がマイクロソフト主催のセキュリティ会議BlueHat Asia 2026で行った講演のスライドに、「エルエルエム、大規模言語モデルを仕事に組み込んだ瞬間、ソフトウェア開発がその上に立っていた『決定論』という信頼性が消えてしまう」という、かなりエンジニアにとっては居心地の悪い内容が書かれています。
彼はまず、「技術には二種類ある」と指摘しています。
たとえば内燃機関のように、原理が先に解明されてから作られたものと、火のように、まず発見されてしまい、仕組みの理解は後回しになるもの。
推論型のエルエルエムは明らかに後者で、私たちは「作った」というより「見つけてしまった」。
改良の方法も理論ではなくて、実験ばかりに頼っている――ここが出発点だと言っています。
そして、コンピューターが決定論的に見えるのは当たり前のことじゃなくて、何世代もの電気系や製造のエンジニアたちが必死に維持してきた、その幻想が三つの段階で崩れてきた、と整理しています。
その三つというのが、ひとつ目がハードウェアの決定論の崩壊。
いわゆるRow Hammerと呼ばれる現象で、これはメモリの特定の場所に高速にアクセスし続けると、隣のデータが勝手に変わってしまうという問題です。
次が時間的決定論の崩壊。
Spectreという名前で知られている、処理を速くするための投機実行やキャッシュが、本来見えてはいけない情報をしょり時間の差として漏らしてしまうもの。
そして三つ目が意味的決定論の崩壊で、これはエルエルエムならではの話です。
エルエルエムはランダムに答えを選ぶうえに、カオス的でもある。
つまりプロンプトをたった一語変えただけで、結果は原理的に「何が起こってもおかしくない」状態になってしまう、という説明なんです。
ここからが彼の本題で、実務の現場で具体的に痛い話に入っていきます。
確率的なシステムの場合、あらゆる変更が仮説検定――それが本当に効果があるかを統計で確かめる作業――になる、と彼は語ります。
例として、クラウド上で性能改善を測定する場合、同じ物理マシンで動いている他社の仮想マシンがどれだけ「うるさい」かだけで、実行時間がプラスマイナス十五パーセントもぶれてしまう。
だから本当に改善したことを示すためには、数百回から数千回も実行する必要があるそうです。
エルエルエムを使ったバグ検出システムでも同じで、「一パーセントの改善を九十五パーセントの精度で検出したい」となると、好都合な仮定を置いたとしても、五十二回のペア実験が必要になる。
プロンプトをちょっと変えるたびにそれ全部やってる人、いったいどれだけいるでしょうか。
そして、彼が導き出した「居心地の悪い結論」は三つ。
まず、ほとんどの人は、事実上スロットマシンを回しているだけだということ。
それから、いま一般的なCアイ・シーディー、つまりコードを変えるたびに自動でテストや配布をしてくれる仕組みは、プロンプトの変更にはまったく向いていない。
最後に、これからは全員が経験科学者であり、素人だろうとプロだろうと「統計家」でなければならない。
彼はまた、エルエルエムによるコードレビューを、従来の静的解析ツールというよりは、「ファジング」、つまりランダムな入力を大量に投げてバグを発見する方法に近いものだと考えています。
まったく同じ設定で再実行しても見つかるバグの集合は毎回異なりますし、プロンプトを少し変更したり、モデルが新しくなってもまた変わります。
だから「終わった」という状態は存在せず、追いかけるべき指標は使った計算リソース、計算費用あたりの有益な発見のわりあい、これだというんです。
私自身も、さいきんはコーディングもコードレビューもエルエルエムに頼りきりなところがあるので、これは少し耳が痛い話です。
エーアイの性能が上がったおかげで、良いコードを作ってくれたり、コードレビューで適切にバグを指摘してくれたりするようになりましたが、それも所詮は確率的な話。
「必要なだけテストもレビューも済ませたから、もう大丈夫だろう」と思ってコードをマージしてしまうのが、いまのばいぶ・コーディングの現実なのかもしれません。
ここからは、「私の目に留まった記事」として、ロボット開発の話題を取り上げていきます。
ロボット開発のオープンソース全体地図についてです。
ロボットの歩く動きの制御や、手先で器用な作業をするためのソフトウェアが、今ではほとんどすべてオープンソースで手に入る状況になった、ということを技術ぶんやごとにまとめた投稿です。
少し前までは、博士号を持った研究者チームが何年もかけて取り組まなければならなかった領域が、いまでは個人や小規模チームであっても、数週間で「シミュレーションでの学習から本物のロボットで動かす」まで一通り実現できるところまで来ている、という主張なんですね。
投稿は中国語ですが、エーアイを使えば簡単に翻訳できますから、ロボットの自作に挑戦してみたい人にはぜひ読んでいただきたい内容です。
かなり具体的に、初心者はどこから手を付ければいいのかなどが書かれている資料で、中国のエンジニアたちがどんなことに夢中で、どうやってオープンソースを活用しているのかを知る意味でも、とても面白いと思います。
[EN]Who Makes Humanoid Robot Actuators? A Global Supplier Map[/EN]
ヒューマノイド、つまり人型ロボットの関節を動かす「アクチュエータ」について、世界中のどこで誰がどの部品を作っているのか、地図みたいに整理した記事です。
ロボットを量産する上で本当のボトルネックがどこにあるのかが、部品単位で見えてくる内容を紹介します。
アクチュエータというのは、ロボットでいう「筋肉」にあたる部品で、関節を実際に動かします。
これを細かく分解すると、電気で回転力を生み出すモーター、回転を遅くして力を強くする減速機、回転軸に取り付けて磁力を生む磁石（ローターマグネット）、回転角度を測るエンコーダー、電流を制御するドライバー基板、荷重を支えるベアリング、それからケースとブレーキ、そういった細かい部品で構成されています。
記事では、こうした部品を「材料」「製造工程」「供給している企業」といった製造業の視点で並べ替え、それぞれについて主要なサプライヤーの名前も挙げています。
減速機一つを見ても、たとえば薄い金属を波打たせて減速する「波動歯車（ハーモニックドライブ）」では日本のHarmonic Drive Systemsや中国のLeaderdrive、Laifual。
重い荷重向けのRV型・サイクロイド型であれば日本のNabtesco。
直線運動を生み出す遊星ローラースクリューとなると、スイスのRollvisやSchaefflerグループのEwellix、といった具合に、方式によって関わるメーカーも違ってきます。
サプライチェーンは日本・ヨーロッパ・中国・韓国・アメリカにまたがっていますが、アメリカ国内の生産がまったく無いわけではありません。
記事で挙げられているのは、マサチューセッツ州のHarmonic Drive LLCによる精密減速機、ミシガン州アルマダにあるEwellixのローラースクリュー工場、カリフォルニア州カマリロのThinGapのモーター生産、そしてサウスカロライナ州サムターのeVACによる磁石工場（二千二十五年に商業生産を開始）などです。
いっぽうで記事が強調しているのは、「ボトルネック」となる部分が、部品によって本質的に二種類あるということです。
ひとつは、原材料や、外から調達してくる完成部品（たとえば磁石やエンコーダー用のチップなど）。
もうひとつは加工の工程そのもの。
たとえば波動歯車の場合は、何度も変形させても精度と耐久性を保つ薄い金属部品をつくるノウハウが必要ですし、遊星ローラースクリューについては、中国メーカーが決算資料で「高精度のねじ研削盤は輸入に頼っていて、値段も高いし納期も長い」と正直に書いています。
そして磁石に関しては、鉱石の採掘段階（中国が二千二十四年に六十パーセント）、その後に化学的に分離・精製する中流工程（同じく九十一パーセント）、粉にして磁場の中で固めて焼く焼結工程（同九十四パーセント）と、三段階すべてが中国に極度に集中していることが、国際エネルギー機関IEAの二千二十六年四月のレポートでも明らかになっています。
まず最初に、鉱山を開けば解決するという単純な話ではなくて、分離の化学や廃棄物処理、そして仕上げの精密加工に至るまで、一貫してすべて揃える必要があるというのが今回の記事の見立てなんです。
先日も対談で中国のサプライチェーンについて話題が出ましたが、磁石だけは中国に頼らずに作ることがとても難しいそうです。
必要な材料を化学的に分離したり精製する過程では、廃液などの形で環境に大きな負荷がかかります。
中国はある広大な地域を、実質的に捨ててもいいようなかたちでその工程を成立させていて、日本やアメリカが同じことをしようとしてもできないそうです。
ただ、突き詰めて考えると、そんなふうに環境に大きな負担をかけないと精製できない素材そのものを使うのは、間違っているとも思えてきます。
Teslaは二千二十三年のインベスター・デイイベントで、「次世代の永久磁石モーターにはレアアースを排除する」ということを宣言し、それを二千二十六年の今になってついに実現したと発表しましたが、その重要性がよくわかります。
[EN]The Robot Hand Is the Whole Map, Shrunk[/EN]
ここからは、「ロボットハンド」にまつわる話題です。
ひとがたロボット、つまりヒューマノイドの部品の中でも、いちばん高価なロボットハンドに焦点を当てて、そのコストがどこに集中しているのか、どの企業がそこをにぎっているのかを投資家の視点で分析した記事を紹介します。
ここでは、エーアイを利用した要約を紹介していきます。
人間のように器用に動く「デクスタラス・ハンド」、つまり器用な手は、いま現在ひとつあたり最大二万ドル、日本円でおよそ三百万円もします。
これがヒューマノイド全体の部品コスト、いわゆるBOM、つまり製品を作るために必要な部品の原価合計の三十パーセント以上を占めているんです。
TeslaのOptimus第三世代の手では、五十個を超えるアクチュエーターが使われていて、二十二の自由度を目指しています。
つまり動きのバリエーションが二十二種類もあるということですね。
課題はモーターの数そのものではなくて、製造時の歩留まりや発熱、そしてそれらすべてを手のひらサイズの中に詰め込むことにあると筆者は指摘しています。
コストの内訳を見ていくと、まず、駆動モーターが約半分を占めます。
一つの手には直径六から八ミリの「コアレスモーター」、これは鉄心のない軽くてレスポンスのいいモーターですが、それが十六から二十個使われているんです。
次にセンサーで、これが全体の約三〇パーセント。
指先の触覚センサーや手首の力覚センサー、そして関節の回転角を測るエンコーダーなどですね。
続いて、減速機やネジなどの伝達機構が約十二パーセント、そして制御基板やチップが三パーセントほどなんです。
高級モーターはスイスのMaxon（マクソン）やドイツのFaulhaber（ファウルハーバー）が一つ五十ドルから八十ドルくらいで握っているんですが、中国の企業が急速に追い上げています。
Aoyiという会社は一個十四ドルほどでコアレスモーターを生産し、MOONS'sでは四十から七十パーセント安い価格で同じような反応速度を実現しています。
センサーについては、中国製の触覚センサーが一個二十八ドルまで安くなった一方で、百万回触れると劣化してしまい、量産に必要な五百万回にはまだ届いていません。
筆者は「コスト面はほぼ解決したが、耐久性はいまだに未解決。
五百万回に耐える安価な触覚センサーを作れる企業が、今後指先を制する」と述べています。
伝達機構で見ると、日本のハーモニック・ドライブ・システムズが世界のシェアを約五十八パーセント握っていますが、中国のLeaderDriveも日本製の四十から六十パーセントの価格でTeslaのメキシコ工場に部品を提供しています。
それに加えて、ロボットハンドを動かす制御チップはSTMicroelectronicsに依存していて、中国の業界分析では「MaxonとSTMicroがこの分野の命運を握っている」とまで書かれています。
ロボットハンドには「性能とコスト、信頼性、この三つは同時には満たせない」という鉄則があります。
このため筆者は「量産すれば安くなる」という考え方には否定的なんですね。
というのも、手のひらのなかに二十個ものモーターや極小のネジ、腱の役割を果たすワイヤーなどをミクロン単位の精度で詰め込む必要があって、実際に組み立てにかかる手間や、その歩留まりがどうしても価格の下限になるからなんです。
もし価格がもっと下がるとすれば、高価な上流部品が中国製に置き換わったとき、ということでした。
さて、筆者が考える投資の優先順位とリスク要因をまとめると、次の通りになります。
まず第1層は、じょうじょうしていて伝達機構を作るメーカー、たとえばハーモニック・ドライブ、ナブテスコ、LeaderDriveです。
ここは最も安全にボトルネックを押さえられる方法です。
第2層は、モーターや、モーター・減速機・センサーを一体化したモジュールを作るメーカーです。
ここにはMOONS'やLeadshine、Zhaowei、Guangzhou Haozhiなどがあります。
第3層がセンサー。
大きな伸びしろがありますが、耐久性の壁を破るような触覚センサーの企業は、まだ未上場だそうです。
リスクとしては、TeslaやFigure、Unitreeなどが、いちばん価値の高い手の部分を自社で開発する流れになっていて、外部の部品メーカーの出番が少なくなる可能性があること。
そしてもう一つ、Tesla Optimusの二千二十六年の生産見通しが五万台から十五万台と三倍もの幅があり、じゅようが読みづらいことです。
[EN]The World is Changing: AI For Creativity[/EN]
続いて、AIとクリエイティビティに関する話題です。
ディズニー・アニメを復活させたり、DreamWorks（ドリームワークス）を立ち上げたハリウッドの大物、ジェフリー・カッツェンバーグ氏が、「エーアイはクリエイターの敵なのか？
」という問いに対して、映画の歴史をふり返りながら、シリコンバレーとハリウッド両方に向けて書いたメッセージが注目されています。
カッツェンバーグ氏は、二千二十三年に「AIツールの登場で、世界最高水準のアニメ制作にかかる時間もコストも、三年以内に最大で九十パーセント下がる」と発言し、これがハリウッドの仲間からは強い反発を受けました。
でも氏は、クリエイターたちの抵抗は自分たちの作品への愛情の裏返しだと理解を示しながら、過去にも同じようなことが何度も起きてきたと振り返ります。
たとえば一九〇六年には、作曲家ジョン・フィリップ・スーザが蓄音機を「人間の技能や魂の代用品だ」と批判しましたが、本当の争点はお金でした。
その結果一九〇九年には著作権法、つまり作品を作った人の権利を守る法律の制定につながりました。
一九二〇年代には、映画に音声がついたことで映画館で生演奏していた数万人の音楽家が職を失った一方で、ミュージカル映画や映画音楽、音響効果といった、新しい大きな芸術分野が誕生しました。
一九八〇〜九〇年代には、ディズニーがPixarと共同で手描きのセル画をコンピュータに置き換える仕組み「CAPS」を開発し、『リトル・マーメイド』や『美女と野獣』『アラジン』『ライオン・キング』などの表現を大きく広げました。
DreamWorksでは手描きアニメをやめて、フルCGスタジオに転換しましたが、新しい道具で最高の仕事をするようになった人もいれば、職を失う人もいたわけです。
カッツェンバーグ氏がウォルト・ディズニーが残した録音やメモから学んだことは、ウォルトは「観客がキャラクターを信じられるかどうか」でアニメを定義していて、道具で定義したことはなかったという点です。
道具は世代ごとに変わっていくものですが、残るのは「センス」と「想像力」。
「だいじなのは“どうやって”ではなく“なぜ”」だと、ジョージ・ルーカスの言葉も引いています。
今の生成系AIがやっかいなのは、それが単なる「道具」を超えて、人間の創造性の少なくとも一部を置き換える存在になりうることです。
今は「何をAIに作らせるか」「どうやって観客を魅了するか」は人間の仕事ですが、AIがもっと進化すれば、その領域にまで踏み込んでくるのは明らかでしょう。
そうなったとき、カッツェンバーグ氏がどんなふうに反応するのか、個人的にも続きが気になるところです。
[EN]Scenarios for Our Economic Future[/EN]
最後に、AIがわたしたちの経済の未来にどんな影響を与えるのか、という話題です。
アンソロピックの経済チームが、AIが二千三十年までにアメリカ経済に与える影響を「控えめ」「大幅」「きょくたん」の三つのシナリオに分けて試算したレポートを紹介します。
AIによる失業や格差の議論は感情論になりがちですが、AI企業自身が実際にモデルを作って数字まで出したという意味で、今回取り上げました。
このレポートは経済学者のAnton KorinekやChad Jonesらが社内で作成し、Daron AcemogluやDavid Autorなど有名な経済学者による外部レビューも行われています。
仕事を「タスクの束」と捉えて、アメリカ労働省のO*NETという、職業ごとにタスクを整理したデータベースを使い、「AIが自動化するタスク」「人間を補助するタスク」「変わらないタスク」「新たに生まれるタスク」と切り分けて、経済全体への影響を計算しているんですね。
三つのシナリオで、二千三十年時点のアメリカ経済規模（ジーディーピー）は次の通りです。
まず控えめな場合、AIの影響はインターネット並みで、ジーディーピーは三十四兆千億ドルとなり、AIがなかった場合と比べてプラス一・六パーセント。
失業率や賃金もほぼ変化がありません。
次に大幅な場合には、知識労働、つまりデスクワークの半分をAIが自律的にこなします。
ジーディーピーは三十六兆三千億ドルでプラス八・三パーセント。
失業率は五パーセントほどに上昇しますが、知識労働者の賃金は横ばいで、それ以外の労働者の賃金は上がる見通しです。
さらに極端な場合、AIが自分自身をどんどん改良し続ける「再帰的自己改善」が起こり、ほとんどの知識労働で人間を上回ります。
ジーディーピーは四十四兆四千億ドルとプラス三十二・四パーセント、四年半ごとに倍増するペースです。
ただこの場合、失業率は普通の不況を超えて歴史的な水準まで跳ね上がり、知識労働者の賃金は一〇パーセント以上も下がると試算されています。
注目すべきは、どのシナリオでも経済は成長する一方で、その果実の分配が大きく変わる点です。
労働者に分配される割合、いわゆる「労働分配率」は、控えめなシナリオだと五十九・四パーセントですが、大幅なシナリオでは五十六・一パーセント、そして極端なシナリオでは四十五・二パーセントまで下がり、残りはAIを所有する企業や投資家など資本側に流れていく、という構図になっています。
それでは、今回のメルマガの内容をお届けします。
まず、「職業をまるごと変えるのは難しく、多くの人が次の仕事を見つけるまでに長い時間がかかる」という話題からです。
このことについて、単なる失業率のすうじだけでなく、職業を移動すること自体が、多くの人々にとって大きな痛みを伴うことだと指摘されています。
レポートでは、「未来は決まっていない」と述べていて、普及のスピードや利益の分配のされ方次第で、結果は大きく変わってくると示唆しています。
そして、いちばん大きな課題を「利益を広く社会で共有すること」だと位置づけています。
アンソロピックは、労働しじょうの混乱への有効な対策を探る研究に資金を提供すること、そしてアメリカ国内外で、利益がより広く行き渡るような政策案を提示することを約束しています。
ただし、このモデルには、政府の政策対応や景気循環、個々の労働者が職を失う際のコストなどは含まれていないことが、しっかり記載されています。
このレポートをどう解釈するかは人それぞれですが、私としてはかなり真剣に検討する価値のある内容だと考えています。
エーアイの能力が急速に高まっているのは事実で、それによって経済は成長するものの、失業率も増える、つまり貧富の差が広がっていくだろうということは、直感的にも明らかだと思います。
こうした変化が実際にどれほどのスピードで進むかを予測するのは簡単ではありませんが、その方向に世の中が向かっているのであれば、それなりの備え、つまり税制や社会保障システムを大幅に変える準備はしておくべきだと私は思います。
続いて、Letian Wang氏のX投稿を取り上げます。
CVPRとECCVで感じた研究者たちの戸惑いについてです。
コンピュータビジョン、つまり画像や映像をコンピュータに理解させる研究分野ですね。
その研究者のLetian Wang氏が、ジーピーティー-6が登場した直後に開かれた学会で、研究者たちが「自分たちの研究はこれからどうなるのか」と不安を感じたり、若手研究者へのアドバイスを投稿していました。
CVPRやECCVは、コンピュータビジョン分野で最も権威ある国際学会ですが、ことしはベテラン研究者を含めて「がっかりした」と語る参加者が多かったそうです。
理由は、ジーピーティー-6のような大規模な基盤モデルが、これまで専門家たちがなんねんもかけて開発してきた個別のモデルを、ひとまとめに飲み込んでしまっているからです。
Wang氏自身も、事前に学習された画像生成モデルを土台に、深度推定や物体の切り出しなど幅広いタスクで、専門のモデルを上回る統一モデル「GenCeption」を発表していて、その話を聞いた博士課程の学生から「自分の研究の方向性に疑問を持つようになった」と言われたことを明かしています。
まさに、かつてBERTやジーピーティー-1の登場で、自然言語しょりの研究者たちのながねんの成果が、一夜にして意味を失ったのと同じ現象が、さらに大きなきぼで起きているというわけです。
オープンエーアイ、アンソロピック、グーグルなどが莫大な計算力を使って、大きぼにマルチモーダル、つまり文章だけでなく画像や音声も同時に処理できるエーアイモデルを進化させた結果、個別の問題に特化したモデルの研究価値がどんどん小さくなってきているというのは、その分野の専門家たちにとって本当に死活問題なんです。
ただ、だからといって前号で紹介したTypesafe エーアイのJEVのような、これまでにない新しいエーアイモデルを作り出すことも十分可能ですし、同じ場所にとどまって嘆いているよりは、自分から既存の枠組みを飛び出した研究をしていくしかない、と私は感じています。
ここで[EN]How to Build a Brain in the AI Age[/EN]、この投稿について紹介します。
「エーアイの時代に生き残るのは『エーアイを学んだ人』ではなく、『考える力を先に身につけた人』だ」と主張するのが、Nathan Critchett氏、『Cognitive Architecture』の著者による投稿です。
「エーアイを学べ」という世間でよく聞く掛け声自体が間違っている、というちょっと逆説的な議論だったので、ここでご紹介します。
Critchett氏は、発達心理学の「水平的発達」と「垂直的発達」という区別を持ち出して説明しています。
水平的発達というのは、新しいツールや知識、スキルを覚えていくこと。
「30日でChatGPTをマスター」といった講座は、すべてこの水平方向の成長に当たります。
たとえば「同じ大きさのコップに水を注ぎ足す」イメージです。
一方で、垂直的発達はその人の考え方の構造自体を変えることで、こちらは「コップそのものを大きくする」と考えるとわかりやすいです。
Critchett氏が学校や企業で3年間観察してきたところ、エーアイツールを導入して全員に研修をしても、実際に成果を出すのはもともと「評価・判断する力」が強かった10から15パーセントの人だけで、残りの人たちは数週間で使うのをやめてしまうそうです。
その根拠として、いくつか調査結果を引用しています。
たとえば Harvard Business Schoolがコンサルティング会社BCGで調べたところ、ふだんからエーアイに頼りがちなコンサルタントは、エーアイが自信満々に間違えたときでも、そのまま信じて間違った回答をしてしまうケースが多いそうです。
また、中国の中高生二万七千人を二年間追跡した調査では、特別な指導も受けずにエーアイを与えられた生徒の半数が、五か月以内に宿題を全部エーアイ任せにするようになり、試験の成績が二十四パーセント下がった結果が出ています。
ただし、Critchett氏はこの数字が「エーアイが有害」だと証明したわけではなく、「思考力の育成なしにエーアイを使うことが有害」だと証明したのだと述べています。
つまり「考えを省くための道具」と「考えを鍛えるための道具」の違いを、誰も教えてこなかったことが問題ということなのです。
これ、とても鋭い指摘だと思いますが、では実際にどうやって「コップ自体を大きくする方法」を見つけていくかというのは、こどもたちの教育だけでなく、人類全体にとって本当に重要なテーマではないかと私は感じました。
場合によっては、人類全体の知能が低下し、コップそのものが小さくなっていく危険性すらあるわけです。
ちなみに筆者が提唱している具体的な手法としては、たとえば、混乱している状態に慣れること、つまり古い見方が通用しなくなり新しい見方もまだ現れていない、そんな「すきま」の時間こそが成長の瞬間だと捉えること。
また「作ること」ではなく「判断すること」を毎日練習する、たとえば一日二十分でも、機械のアウトプットを疑い反論してみること。
「このツールをどう使うか」ではなく「このツールには何が見えていないのか」「そもそも正しい問題を解いているのか」と問い直してみることなどが挙げられています。
確かに参考にはなりますが、これを具体的な学習プランとして落とし込むのは、なかなか簡単ではないなという印象もあります。
次に、[EN]100 Hours Inside Kimi[/EN] のご紹介です。
中国のエーアイスタートアップ、Moonshot エーアイ、Kimiの開発元ですね。
こちらにライターが百時間密着して、社内の雰囲気や動きを描いたルポ記事です。
部署も肩書きも評価制度もない、本当にエーアイネイティブな組織がどんなふうに動いているのか、とてもよくわかる記事だったのでご紹介します。
Moonshot エーアイは創業三年で、企業評価額が千二百億元、日本円で約二兆四千億円を超えています。
社員は三百人強、平均年齢は三十歳未満。
社員一人あたりが背負う企業価値は約四億元、つまり八十億円にもなります。
ただし、二千二十四年末には、春節向けマーケティング計画を六回もやり直させられた若手社員が会議室で泣き出すほど社内が混乱していたそうです。
そして翌月、DeepSeekが登場したことで「Kimiはもう過去の会社なんじゃないか」という空気になり、経営陣はそのタイミングで、広告中心の戦略からモデル開発に集中する方針に切り替えました。
社内ではこの出来事を「DeepSeekに救われた」と言い表しているそうです。
記事で紹介されていたMoonshot エーアイの特徴としては、こんなものが挙げられています。
まず、部署や階層、肩書きが一切なく、OKRやKPIといった目標管理やすうじ目標も存在せず、出退勤の記録もありません。
中間管理職を持たず、共同創業者五人がそれぞれ四十人から五十人の社員と直接やりとりする、非常にフラットな構造になっています。
採用で一番重視されるのは「センス」だそうで、過去一年間の採用百人以上は、すべて社員からの紹介で採用されてきました。
社員の八割は内向的な性格で、対人コミュニケーションよりもエーアイとのやり取りを好むタイプです。
大手企業から来た中堅や幹部クラスがなじめずに辞めていく例も複数あり、「経験や肩書きが逆に重荷になる」と証言する人もいました。
社内でよく使われるフレーズは「直接コミュニケーションしろ」。
つまり、誰かの助けが必要なときは、上司を通さず本人にすぐ頼みに行くのが普通だそうです。
技術面では、モデルの学習が「錬金術」と呼ばれていて、学習が始まると毎朝数十万個の指標を眺めて異常値を探し、極端な値になった学習データがあれば、「容疑者を尋問するように」一つずつチェックしていくといった状況です。
百二十八Kという業界を大きく上回る長文脈対応を実現するまでに、三度計画が白紙になり、そのたびに立ち上がったことから「三度の反省の崖」という社内エピソードも生まれています。
そして最後の質問「この会社を一言で言うなら？
」に対して、あるエンジニアが「月面着陸」と答え、ケネディの「難しいからこそ月に行く」という言葉を引用していました。
一方で、記事はこの極端にフラットな組織の弱点についても指摘しています。
ホラクラシー、つまり階層のない組織運営の過去の実例では、五百人を超えたあたりで意思決定が詰まってしまい、上からの目標がないことで「朝会社に出ても何をすべきかわからない」と嘆いて大手企業に戻った元社員もいます。
執筆者はこれを、SF小説「三体」に出てくる、次元を潰す兵器「二向箔」、つまり三次元空間を二次元に押しつぶしてしまう兵器になぞらえて、Moonshot エーアイは自ら組織をどんどん平らにしていく賭けをしている、と分析しています。
モデルの知能が十分に高まればこの賭けは正当化されるが、そうでなければ組織が崩壊する。
「第三の道はない」と、記事は締めくくられていました。
Kimiは最近よく話題に上がりますが、DeepSeekの登場でこんな危機を迎えていたとは知らなかったので、とても興味深く読ませてもらいました。
DeepSeekが「DeepSeekショック」と言われるほどアメリカのかぶしきしじょうに大きなインパクトを与えたという話はよく知られていますが、実は中国国内でも同じくらいのインパクトが広がっていたことを、私は最近になって知ったんです。
[EN]Meta has just unveiled their new VR glasses[/EN]
ここからは、メタがヘッドバンド不要でメガネのようにかけられる新しいVR、つまり仮想現実グラスを発表した、という話題です。
価格は一千二百九十九ドル、およそ十九万円で、発売は二千二十七年春を予定しているとのことです。
このVRグラスの最大の特徴は、重さがわずか百グラムしかないということで、これはトランプ一組ほどの軽さです。
今までのゴーグル型VR機器に比べて、はるかに軽いんですね。
この軽さを実現するために、メガネ本体にはディスプレイとセンサーだけを載せて、プロセッサー、バッテリー、ストレージといった計算やデータ保存などの重要なパーツは、「パック」と呼ばれる別の小型ユニットにまとめて入れているんです。
主なスペックをご紹介します。
まず、五ケーのマイクロ有機ELディスプレイを採用。
つまり、非常に小さくて高精細な自発光ディスプレイです。
画素密度は三十七PPD、これは視野角一度あたりのピクセル数という意味で、数字が大きいほど映像がきめ細かいことを示しています。
さらに、薄型の「パンケーキレンズ」を独自設計していて、映像規格であるDolby Vision、そして立体音響のDolby Atmosにも対応しています。
[EN]QualcommのSnapdragon Reality Eliteチップを搭載[/EN]
バッテリーは連続再生で最大三時間。
急速充電は四十五ワットに対応しています。
さらに、フルカラーのパススルーカメラが付いていて、外の景色も映し出せますし、側面が開いたデザインなので、つけたままでも周囲を見ることができます。
操作はコントローラーが不要で、音声や視線の動き、つまりアイトラッキング、それから手のジェスチャーで行えるようになっています。
さらに、メタのエーアイアシスタント「メタ エーアイ」が基本ソフト、つまりオーエスに直接組み込まれています。
使い道としては、映画やスポーツ観戦など、動画の視聴に力を入れている印象があります。
VR機器としては初めてIMAXの「IMAX Enhanced」認証を取得していて、いちぶの映画はIMAXの拡張された画面比率で見ることができますし、Disney+ではいちぶの三D映画が体験できるようになっています。
Disney+やPrime Video、YouTube、ESPNなど、多くの動画配信サービスと提携していて、スポーツは八ケー・百八十度の映像で、まるで最前列にいるかのような臨場感だそうです。
さらに、WhatsAppやZoomといった通話アプリにも対応しています。
私は「これは買うしかないな」と感じました。
アップルのVision Proは描画性能はとても高いのですが、重くて目が疲れてしまうのが難点なんですよね。
もちろん、軽いからといって必ずしも疲れないという保証はありませんが、VRやARグラスを普及させるという意味では、これはかなり大きな一歩だと思っています。
上で触れたMulmoChatを、この新しいデバイス向けに最適化してみるのも面白そうだなと感じました。
ここからは、質問コーナーです。
まず一つめのご質問です。
「半導体関連株はここ数年かなり注目されており、エーアイの進化に伴って今後も半導体じゅようはさらに拡大していくと考えられています。
特にエーアイ関連では、今後もデータセンターやジーピーユーなどへの投資が続くことで、半導体関連企業の業績や株価も引き続き上昇すると見る方が多い印象です。
一方で、私は少し別のリスクもあるのではないかと考えています。
中国の半導体企業もここ数年でかなり技術力を高めており、最先端半導体はともかく、汎用的な半導体やメモリについては、中国国内での生産能力が高まることで、今後価格が下落する可能性があるのではないかと思っています。
特に気になっているのが、中国の半導体自給率が高まった場合の影響です。
例えば、サムスンやSK hynixなどのメモリメーカーは中国向けの販売比率も高く、中国が政策的にメモリの国産化を進め、これまで海外から輸入していた汎用メモリを国内企業で賄えるようになれば、世界的なメモリ需要や価格形成にも影響が出るのではないかと考えています。
そうなると、エーアイ向けの最先端メモリ（HBMなど）のじゅようは引き続き強くても、汎用メモリの価格下落によって、サムスンやSK hynixなどの業績や株価には下押し圧力がかかる可能性もあるのではないでしょうか。
つまり、「エーアイによって半導体じゅようが拡大する」という大きな流れがある一方で、中国の半導体自給率向上によって、最先端以外の半導体・メモリが供給過剰になり、価格が下落するという逆方向の力もあるのではないか、というのが私の考えです。
この点について中島さんはどのようにお考えでしょうか？
」
これについての私の回答です。
半導体と言ってもいろいろありますが、ご指摘のあったメモリに関しては、既存のメーカーが過剰投資を避けるために設備投資に慎重になる中で、中国のメーカーが量産に走ると、いつものように供給が過剰になって、値段が下がるというサイクルが近いうちにやってくる可能性は十分にあると思います。
一方、エヌビディアのジーピーユーのように簡単にはコモディティ化しない半導体もあって、必ずしも中国メーカーの台頭が全ての半導体の価格を押し下げるとは限らない、と私は考えます。
続いてのご質問です。
「中島さんのメルマガにも登場されるものづくり太郎さんがコラボしていた、ジムケラーのテンストレントの半導体設計についてのアプローチについて、中島さんの意見をぜひ伺いたいです。
」
これについてお答えします。
ジム・ケラーは私が最も尊敬する半導体せっけいエンジニアですので、テンストレントには非常に期待しています。
私の理解では、テンストレントの特徴にはこのような点があります。
エヌビディアのジーピーユーのように、メモリ（HBM）とジーピーユーとの間でデータをやり取りしながら計算するのではなく、テンシックスと呼ばれるSRAMを持った計算ノード間で、チップ内はネットワーク・オン・チップ、チップ間はイーサネット経由で、直接データを流すことで計算する、データフロー・アーキテクチャを採用していること。
そして、ジーピーユーやシーピーユーのようにハードウェアが自動的にどのデータを、計算コアのすぐ近くにあるSRAMにキャッシュするかを決めるのではなく、テンシックスの中に複数置かれたシーピーユーが、どのデータをSRAMに持たせるか、どのデータを別のテンシックスに流すかを、ソフトウェアがコントロールする仕組みになっています。
また、ASICのように特定モデルに特化したハードではなくて、どんなモデルにも対応できる汎用ハードであること。
さらに、ライセンス料がかからず自由度の高いRISC-Vを使っていることも特徴です。
ジム・ケラーご本人も対談の中で話していましたが、コードが書けるエーアイが登場したことで、エヌビディアのジーピーユーと違ってCUDAを持たないテンストレント上でモデルを動かすためのソフトウェアを作るコストが、非常に大きく下がっている点は、テンストレントにとって大きな追い風となるでしょう。
では、続いてのご質問です。
「今週号で、フィジカルエーアイについて触れられていました。
その中で、QDD（準ダイレクトドライブ）と高減速比のハーモニックドライブの特性の比較が印象的でした。
ソフトウェアを専門にしてこられた中で、モーターや減速機の分野まで理解を深めておられる点が興味深かったです。
そこで、モーターや減速機の特性までご自身で学ばれているのは、ひとつはQDDとハーモニックドライブのような複数の設計選択肢について自分で判断できるレベルまで理解するためでしょうか？
それとも、エーアイを活用することを前提に、エーアイが示す説明や結論の妥当性を見極めるための土地勘を得るためでしょうか？
」
このご質問に対しての回答です。
減速機については、ひとがたロボットに欠かせない部品を勉強していた時に学びました。
最初は「アクチュエーター」という言葉の意味すらちゃんと理解できていませんでしたからね。
それで、ハーモニック・ドライブの構造に興味を持って、どんどん深掘りしたんです。
QDDについては、中国製ロボットが飛んだり跳ねたりしている動画を見て、テスラのOptimusとの違いを調べているうちに、必然的にたどり着きました。
どちらの場合も、特に何か目的があったというより、知識欲が刺激されて「もっと知りたい」と思ったから深堀りした、ただそれだけの話なんです。
さらに次のご質問です。
「PFNが三菱重工から百億円の出資を受け、アイピーオーを視野に入れていると報じられています。
PFNは、ジェンスン・フアンが言う『五層のケーキ』のうち、チップ、計算基盤、モデル、アプリの四層を自前で持っています。
しかし、それぞれの層でNvidiaやオープンエーアイのような世界レベルの専業企業に勝つのは難しいのではないでしょうか。
実際の拠り所は、国産であることを求める防衛やインフラ、政府のじゅように見えます。
PFNの垂直統合は勝てる筋になりそうでしょうか？
それとも、チップなど一層にしぼるべきでしょうか？
（主力のMN-Coreも、本格的な外販はまだこれからと理解しています）」
このご質問についての回答です。
オープンエーアイが独自のエーアイチップを作ってきたことを見ても、垂直統合戦略自体は悪いものではないと私は考えます。
PFNが三菱重工から出資を受けたのも、「国産チップ・国産モデル」を日本の防衛やインフラに使うことを日本政府が重視しているからだ、と解釈してもいいと思います。
もちろん、だからといってPFNが世界しじょうで必ず成功するという保証はありません。
ただ、まずは日本しじょうでしっかり足場を固めて、キャッシュフローを生み出せる体制を作ることが何より大事なので、とても良い動きだと私は思います。
さて、次のご質問へ移っていきます。
最初のご質問ですが、中島さんはメタトレンドの初期段階で複数の企業に少額分散投資をされているということですね。
たとえばDuolingoやGroqのような新しいトレンド候補に投資を始める際、リスク管理の観点から『新規探索、つまり実験枠』の合計は、投資資金全体の最大でも何割程度までに抑えるといったような、何かご自身の中でのルールを設定されているのでしょうか、というご質問です。
これについての中島さんの回答です。
実験枠の合計の上限は、特に決めていません。
ただし、ひとつの銘柄あたり、さいしょに投資する金額は本当にわずかなもので、およそゼロ点一からゼロ点五パーセントぐらいです。
それによって自分ごととして関わり始め、期待通りにその企業が成長してくれれば、ドルコスト平均法で少しずつ買い増しをしていきます。
逆に、期待通りではなかった場合は手放すという運用をしているということです。
続いてのご質問です。
私は国立大学の機械工学科に在籍している三年生で、半導体製造装置メーカーでの研究開発職を目指しています。
さいきん悩んでいるのは、アウトプットの場の違いについてです。
情報系の学生は、長期インターンや個人開発、OSSへの貢献などを通して、学部生のうちから実務に近い成果を積み上げられます。
しかし、機械系の場合は実機や設備、材料費が必要なこともあって、研究室に配属される四年生までは、授業の課題やサークルでの製作以外に評価されるアウトプットを出せる場が限られていると感じています。
ただ、今号のジーピーティー-6 Astraが部品表からBreguetの懐中時計をギアの歯数まで再現したという話や、ヒューマノイドに必要な多くの部品を日本企業が作っているという話を読んで、エーアイの登場によって機械系の学生にも手元でできることが広がっているのではと感じました。
そこで質問です。
もし中島さんが今、機械系の学部生だったら、研究室に配属される前の時間を使って、どのような形でアウトプットをしますか？
また、機械系の学生がエーアイを活用してハードウェア分野で成果を出すには、どんな方法があるとお考えでしょうか。
このご質問への中島さんの回答です。
上にも書きましたが、小規模なもので良いので、実際にロボット、自動運転車、ドローンといったものを作って経験を積むのが良いだろうと思います。
もし私が採用する立場だった場合、機械系の学科を卒業したのに、そのような経験を学校外で全くしていない学生を見ると、何か、たとえば機械に対する熱意などが根本的に欠けていると感じてしまいます。
次のご質問です。
最近、TypesafeエーアイのJEVのような、生成ではなく高速な判断に特化したエーアイが出てきて面白いと感じています。
ですが、こうした分野は今後、フロンティアモデルを持つ大手企業からも似たような機能が次々と出てくるのではないかとも思っています。
その一方で、最近は個人的にCloudflareの動きが非常に面白いと感じていて、Workersやエーアイ関連機能などを含めると、今後アプリケーションかいはつの基盤としてさらに存在感が大きくなるのではないかと注目しています。
中島さんご自身が最近開発されているアプリケーションではCloudflareを使うことはありますか？
また今のCloudflareを開発者の立場からどのように評価されているか、今後の可能性も含めてお聞きしたいです。
これに対する中島さんの回答です。
私は、メルマガ向けの画像配信と、MulmoServerのシーディーエヌでCloudflareを使っています。
全部の機能を使っているわけではありませんが、エーダブリューエスとは一味違う良いサービスを提供している、しっかりとした会社だという印象です。
つまり簡単には倒産しないしっかりした企業だと思っています。
エーアイについてもチャンスはあるのではと思っていますが、ネオクラウドのようにエーアイデータセンターに莫大な投資をするようなビジネスではないので、Cloudflareなりにどんな形で価値を生み出していくのか、非常に興味を持ちながら見ています。
ちなみに、私はCloudflareの株も少しだけ保有しています。
続いて、マルモサーバーについてのご質問です。
チャッピーに聞きながらマルモクロードを設定できるようになり、少しずつ自分の使いたいアプリも作っています。
そこで、パソコンがネット接続していないとマルモサーバーを通してスマホで入力や更新ができないことに悩んでいます。
もし方法がありましたらご教示いただけると幸いです。
具体的には、読んだ本、作ったレシピ、健康管理、たとえば体重や筋トレの記録などのコレクションを、パソコンは常に開いていないためスマホをメインで入力していきたいと考えています。
これに対する中島さんの回答です。
MulmoClaudeで作るアプリ、つまりコレクション・アプリはデータをパソコンに格納してあるため、家のパソコンが動いていないと家の外からデータにアクセスできない設計になっています。
MulmoClaudeの兄弟分にあたるMulmoTerminalというサービスには「共有アプリ」という仕組みが備わっていて、それを使うとパソコンなしで同様のアプリを動かすことも可能になります。
ですが、その場合データはすべてサーバーに格納されるため、「誰がアクセスできるか」という点をはっきりさせておかないと、他人にデータを見られてしまう可能性がありますのでご注意ください。
次のご質問です。
堀江貴文さんのメルマガをよく読んでいますが、エーアイの普及によってこれからのこどもたちの学力の高低差、そして勉強が意味がなくなるという意見をよく見かけます。
たとえば偏差値の高い大学を目指す意味がもうない、と。
エーアイを使いこなしてビジネスの現場に身を置く方が、よっぽど本人のためになるという考え方についてどう思われますか？
私にもこどもがいて、何となく塾には通わせています。
私は勉強が意味がなくなるとは思っていません。
もちろん高学歴であれば仕事ができるかは別としても、エーアイを駆使するのにもそれなりの頭は必要だと感じます。
また、薬剤師や、かんたんには取れない資格の価値が今後どうなっていくか、中島さんのお考えを伺いたいです。
ここから中島さんの回答です。
従来型の、「記憶に頼った学力」や、「知識を単に詰め込むだけの勉強」というものについては、たしかに意味がなくなっていくと思います。
ただ、「エーアイを駆使してビジネスを成功させる」にはそれなりの知恵と工夫と努力が必要なので、そんなに甘いものではありません。
エーアイは「何かを作りたいという意思」や、「これをたいせつだと考える価値観」を持ち合わせていません。
それらを提供してエーアイを正しい方向に導いていくのは、やはり人間の役割です。
学生時代に何の勉強もしてこなかった人が、そうした役割をきちんと果たせるとは、私は思いません。
また、薬剤師の資格を取るのに何が必要か、私は詳しくは知りませんが、本やパソコンで勉強しただけで取得できるような資格については、今後価値がなくなっていくと考えた方が良いと思います。
逆に、医師、特に外科医や、電気工事士のように実際に手を動かさなければならないような資格の価値は、これからも長く残ると思います。
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。